en el vídeo anterior vimos cómo obtener
esta ecuación usando mucha física y de
hecho no es necesario ver el vídeo
anterior pueden comenzar con este vídeo
si así lo quieren dijimos que es uno es
la energía asociada con un electrón en
el nivel de energía más bajo del
hidrógeno y usamos el modelo de voz y
calculamos el valor de dicha energía
igual a menos 2.17 por 10 a la menos 18
jules vamos a convertir esto en electrón
volts lo que nos facilita trabajar con
los números un electrón bolt es 1.6 por
10 al menos 19 jules así que tengo menos
2.17 por 10 a la menos 18 jules y
sabemos que un electrón bolt es igual a
1.6 por 10 al menos 19
aquí tengo un factor de conversión por
lo que si multiplico estos dos los jules
se cancelan y nos quedan electrón volts
como unidades y si hacemos los cálculos
nos quedan menos 13.6 electrón volts
esta es la energía asociada al electrón
en el nivel de energía más bajo del
hidrógeno pongo esto en mi ecuación y la
re escribo la energía a cualquier nivel
energético m es igual a 1 que es menos
13.6 electrón volts y lo dividimos entre
n al cuadrado n es un entero 123
etcétera la energía del primer nivel de
energía 1 ya sabemos cuánto es pero
vamos a calcular la para familiarizarnos
con la fórmula
es menos 13.6 entre 1 n es igual a 1 y
el número que tengamos aquí lo vamos a
poner aquí será 1 al cuadrado que es
igual a 1 por lo que nos queda menos
13.6 electrón volts lo que ya sabíamos
calculemos la energía del segundo nivel
que es menos 13.6 entre 2 al cuadrado y
si hacemos los cálculos nos queda menos
3.4 electrón volts
y hagamos una más la energía asociada al
tercer nivel es menos 13.6 entre 3 al
cuadrado
pues ahora n es igual a 3 lo que nos da
menos un 1.51 electrón voltios
así que tenemos la energía asociada de
tres niveles de energía diferentes y uno
es menos 13.6 electrón volts y dos es
menos 3.4 electrón volts y el 3 es menos
1.51 electrón bots la energía es
cuántica da usando el modelo de vor así
que no podemos tener un valor de energía
entre estos niveles de energía también
noten que estos niveles de energía son
negativos así que este es el nivel más
alto de energía el 3 es el más cercano a
cero de los tres niveles de energía que
tenemos aquí ahora hablemos del modelo
de board del átomo de hidrógeno
recordemos que ya habíamos visto cómo
obtener estos radios del modelo de board
y esto no está dibujado a escala pero si
suponemos que tenemos un núcleo
positivamente cargado que acabo de
marcar aquí con rojo sabemos que en el
modelo de vor los electrones orbitan al
núcleo
vamos a dibujar un electrón aquí
nuevamente el dibujo no está escala
este electrón va a estar orbitando al
núcleo que va a traer al electrón por su
carga positiva y éste electrón va a
estar
orbitando en r1 que es el primer radio
de aquí ese uno es cuando en es igual a
uno y ya calculamos esta energía cuando
n es igual a uno la energía es de menos
13.6 electrón volts esta es la energía
asociada con el electrón en su órbita
alrededor del núcleo
aquí a la derecha si decimos que en esta
línea la energía es igual a cero y aquí
abajo está menos 13.6 electrón bolt y
recuerden que nada de esto está dibujada
escala es solo para que nos demos una
idea de lo que está ocurriendo esto es
cuando n es igual a 1 el electrón está a
una distancia r 1 del núcleo hablamos
del primer nivel de energía y tiene una
energía de menos 13.6 electrón volts
asociada con dicho electrón
ahora digamos que el electrón se
encuentra a una distancia r 2 del núcleo
ahora n es igual a 2 y calculamos su
energía que es menos 3.4 electrón volts
ahora imaginemos que el electrón se
encuentra a una distancia r 3 del núcleo
esto es cuando en es igual a 3 y
calculamos que esa energía es igual a
menos un 1.51 electrón volts es útil
comparar ambos diagramas al mismo tiempo
ya que nos ayuda a comprender mejor este
concepto de energía
por ejemplo digamos que queremos
promover al electrón que dibuje del
nivel de menor energía a un nivel más
alto
una vez que agreguemos la energía
necesaria al electrón para hacer que
este pase del nivel 1 al segundo nivel
de energía y ahora en el electrón va a
estar aquí a este electrón tuvimos que
darle toda esta cantidad de energía
la diferencia de energía entre estos dos
niveles de energía que es la diferencia
entre estos dos números y si pensamos en
términos de la magnitud 13.6 menos 3.4
será una magnitud de 10.2 electrón volts
si le damos a este electrón 10.2
electrón voltios de energía podemos
hacer que ese electrón salte de este
primer nivel de energía hasta el segundo
nivel de energía pero tenemos que
proporcionarle exactamente esta cantidad
de energía para que lo logre
ahora digamos que queremos que nuestro
electrón pase del primer nivel de
energía directamente al tercer nivel de
energía
aquí tenemos nuestro electrón y haremos
que llegue hasta acá para hacerlo
tendremos que proporcionarle la energía
necesaria y pensando la magnitud tenemos
13.6 electrón volts menos 1.51 electrón
volts tendríamos la energía necesaria
para causar esta transición y esto sería
12.09 electrón volts
por lo que si le damos al electrón 12.09
el electrón volts de energía lo podemos
promover a un nivel de mayor energía y
la última situación que nos falta ver es
tomar al electrón vamos a dibujarlo aquí
una vez más en el primer nivel de
energía y le damos la suficiente
cantidad de energía para llevarlo a una
distancia e infinitamente lejos del
núcleo de nuevo aquí no lo estoy
dibujando a escala si el electrón está
infinitamente lejos de él
no tendrá ninguna fuerza de atracción
hacia el núcleo así que no habrá ninguna
fuerza de atracción ya antes habíamos
hablado de la ley de coulomb y es aquí
cuando r es igual a infinito y como no
hay fuerza de atracción no va a haber
energía potencial y la forma que
definimos la energía potencial eléctrica
es que es igual a cero cuando eres
infinita así que la energía potencial
eléctrica es cero y si no se está
moviendo su energía cinética también
será cero por lo que la energía total
será cero esto es lo que significa el
diagrama de la derecha cuando es igual a
cero estamos hablando de que el electrón
está a una distancia infinita del núcleo
así que podemos decir que n es igual a
infinito el recibo al infinito y si no
se está moviendo su energía total será
igual a cero cuando alejamos el electrón
totalmente del núcleo lo hemos
guionizado pasamos de un átomo de
hidrógeno neutro a un niño
de hidrógeno lo que se expresa como h
más pasamos de h&h más para lograr esto
necesitamos una gran cantidad de energía
esto es de tener el electrón aquí abajo
a tenerlo hasta aquí arriba
cuál será esta magnitud de energía pues
es de 13.6 electrón volts
esta es la energía necesaria para quitar
al electrón del tirón de atracción del
núcleo y volverlo unión s 13.6 electrón
volts corresponde a la energía de
ionización para el hidrógeno así que el
modelo de boro predice correctamente la
energía de ionización para el hidrógeno
esta es una razón de por qué es bueno
estudiar este modelo no sólo estos
radios están cuántica 2 también lo están
estos niveles de energía